- Why are all the ghosts white?
- That's a-- yeah.
- You don't think any slaves
have unfinished business?
- Interesting now,
because like you know,
if you live in certain
gentrified neighborhoods,
you can't tell if that person's
a ghost or just a hipster.
You don't know,
some of the clothes
these people are wearing.
- Oh.
- You have people out there
on the bus dressed like
Civil War generals.
- Yeah.
- Just on the bus.
- And they're not
healthy, so you're like,
that's probably--
- Yeah, like this
guy has scurvy.
- You shouldn't be translucent.
(rock music)
- What's up everybody,
welcome to Stupid Questions,
I'm Chris Distefano,
AKA Chrissy the Nipple
with me, Josh Johnson.
Writer for The Daily Show,
got a great album
out called I Like You
and he did a half hour
special last year.
I do like you.
- Thank you
- You're a good kid,
you got good energy.
- I like you too.
- Appreciate it.
(rock music)
- I think I'd be an avocado.
- Wow, is that--
that is a fruit.
- Yeah.
- Why would you want
to be an avocado?
- The seed is, like,
indestructible.
- You can't destruct
that seed, yeah.
- White women would be all
over me, if I was an avocado.
- 100%
- That, or like an iced latte.
But like, since you
asked me a fruit,
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna say a fruit.
- Avocado. Or if you
were a sushi? Oh my god.
- Yeah
- White girls love sushi.
- Also whole
countries love sushi.
(rock music)
My uncle.
My uncle's, like,
never had a good job.
- Right. Yeah.
- And you can tell he's
never had a good job
because he, like, never
answers with one or two words.
Straight up, when you
ask him what he does
he's like, "Well, what
you gotta know is.."
and it's like "No," (laughs)
"that's not how jobs work.
"Just tell me what you do."
- I'm an electrician.
Tell you what I'm doing
- Exactly, get to it.
There was one time where
I straight up was asking
my uncle right, "How you
been, what you been up to?"
He's like, "Well you
like turkey, right?"
And I'm like, "No, just
tell me what you do."
Now it turns out, turkeys
can't even breed naturally,
- Right
- So someone has to
jerk turkeys off.
He was like a turkey jerker.
"Look, you want thanksgiving,
you gotta come through me"
(rock music)
Throwing up.
- Yeah.
- I've never seen,
like a hot throw up.
- Yeah
- I've never seen
someone be like, "Blah."
- Yeah
- You know what I mean?
It's always like,
"Graah!" (laughs)
Have you ever met somebody
who, like, throws up
when they see people throw up?
- Oh yeah, it's hilarious.
- OK, so I have a
friend that's in Chicago
and my buddy and I would
just stand next to him
and be like, "Hey do you
guys want to- (gagging)"
- Yeah
- And he'd be like,
"What are you doing?"
And we'd be like,
"Nothing- (gagging)"
And we only ever did it
once because we felt so bad
about it once it
actually happened.
- Yeah
- It's like poking the bear.
- Right
- And then he actually
threw up. And we were like,
oh we gotta, like, take care
of him and stuff. (laughs)
(rock music)
- What we do no this show is
you answer stupid questions
you get a stupid gift.
So I got you a gift.
What this is, it's
a turtleneck bib.
Because you have like a joke
and you have bitch
hands or something.
So we figured that this
just encompasses a person
who says that he can't
choke someone out sexually.
- I never said that I had--
- Its a turtleneck.
- Oh no, it looks completely
useless, thank you.
- Do you like the gift?
- Send the- No! I don't
like the gift at all.
And you said that
I had bitch hands.
- Put it on.
Oh yeah.
(laughs)
- Then why is the
bib on the back?
(Chris laughs)
What is this? Is this so
you don't have to clean it,
you can just switch it around?
What is this trash?
- Look at this idiot.
- Why are there two sides?
- Just smile.
- No, I'm not gonna
smile. I don't like this.
This is dumb
- I can even
remember which side--
- Anger
- This looks like
a bad porn outfit.
- Hey, people are into that.
- No, no one is into this.
(rock music)